[Music]
for this week on the boys it was a win
for team Miley on the iTunes charts
right tell my team yes Addison and
Carly's unique version of Cyndi Lauper's
classic girls just want to have fun
became the show's very first single to
enter the top 100 the season and
meanwhile Cyndi herself is still making
music today eg online simply she lacy
was in the studio with the 80s pop icon
who's still showing her true colors
[Music]
a 64 Cindy is still having fun rocking
that pink hair is there a typical day in
the life of Cindy Lauper well yeah you
have to get up at a certain time because
my dog Gordy he expects to eat at 8
o'clock but what you might not know this
woman who was born to stand out was once
hiding a health issue
aiex Rice's and I was very very sick
now she's teamed up with Novartis
helping others with the disease through
their see me to know campaign is to hear
their stories and how they dealt with it
and to know you're not alone and you
don't have to be invisible
[Music]
I'm not writing a song called oh I'm not
doing that the first thing I did I'm
Christoph oh you gotta give people hope
so what's next for Cindy she's bringing
working girl to Broadway designing her
own clothing line and keeping her health
a priority I workout you have to
exercise I want to be fit and strong
[Music]